let's talk about your grandfather and
about Specter and how those two things
came to coalesce in the original idea
for how you're gonna make this movie
they were the same person
okay my grandfather fought in the in the
war obviously you can see that the movie
is dedicated to him he fought in war
from 16 to 18 and he was 17 years old
but he didn't speak of the experience at
all to his own children it was only when
he got into his 70s that he started
talking to his grandchildren about it
and so I have very vivid memories of him
I must have been about 11 or 12 he was a
very small wiry theatrical great
storyteller and we all adored him and he
but he told stories that were shocking
they weren't stories of heroism or
bravery they were unadorned stories of
horror really the the scale of the war
and how lucky he was to have survived it
you know and the the luck and
coincidence and accidental heroism he
won two medals but he claimed that it
was entirely by accident and he told one
story about about being sent as a
messenger across no-man's land with one
message and it was that image of that
little person in the mist carrying that
one message that really inspired the
movie I just thought what if he kept
going and that's what we turned into
this story the bond I'm assuming you
mean when I when I what gave me the
courage to write the story was having
spent five years on the Bond movies in a
sense creating with the writers
something from nothing
in both cases I I didn't inherit
anything at the beginning of the process
and I sat in the room with the writers
and watch something be created from the
blank page and I did think to myself
perhaps I could do this myself for the
first time and so that's what drove me
to put together a story and I worked out
the various story points and beats and
then I stalled and then I'd already
worked on a script very successfully I
felt with Christie for something that
for reasons I won't bore you with didn't
come off but
it seemed an obvious port of call and
she was the person who crystallized that
brought it into script form Christy when
you have the idea of the form and you
also have the idea of the story which
one wins and how it is formed start
dictating story and how to story dictate
form in terms how you're gonna shoot the
film and what you can and cannot do
story wise I mean story always wins I
think everyone on this stage will tell
you story wins I mean you can do amazing
things with a camera but what's the
point if you don't care about the
characters you're following so that I
mean we sat down and when we first kind
of wrote this we never thought always
any of this achievable in fact I often
thought most of it was completely
unaware that I was working with salmon
and he knew what he was doing I am so
yes story is is always the principle
Roger you have this early conversation
with Sam about his intentions and it's
obviously a bold idea at what point do
you start trying to figure out whether
or not it's attainable and what you're
gonna have to do to attain it way after
we figured out the what the shots were
we we started off just discussing the
overall so conception of how we were
going to move the camera relative to the
actors and you know to visualize the
story but we said we had his pact that
we wouldn't think about the technology
we wouldn't think how to do it we would
sort of dream about what we wanted to do
and it was only after you know we still
rebooted for months and then we started
rehearsing with Dean and George for
months as well and there's only when
really all the shots were laid out and
then we sort of broke it down into
sections depending on the location of
where we were on depending on the the
performance and how Sam wanted to break
it down into sections of performance
undone and also sometimes in terms of
what equipment would do that particular
piece of work you know something else
you can't do Lee is you can't fix it in
post the shot either has to work or it
doesn't and what does that mean
editorially in terms of how you are
looking at footage that's coming in and
what does and does not make your edit
it's pure terror on a daily basis fear
because every time I looked at
we were building the film as we were
going and I was talking to Sam a lot
every morning and the film just had to
work there was no going back it wasn't
the usual situation with coverage where
you know we could look at something that
was a little bit you know ropey and you
could fix it in post you could polish it
you could have the length of it you
could just suppose the scenes you
couldn't do any of that so this film had
to be kind of perfect every day and that
was kind of nothing I've experienced
before and it was yeah it was really
exciting and it's like a I sort of
described it once as like Christmas
because every morning you know you'd be
watching each of these takes unfold and
at one point there was 39 of them and at
some points are there none of them if
there's daylight issues or you don't get
a shot that you actually in some days
the guys you know I come in and my
assists and I'd sit there all happy to
unwrap my Christmas present he say you
got nothing
lumber coal and so you know and then
we'd realize we'd here during the day
that they couldn't shoot but you know
they use that to their advantage and
rehearsed and then you know because
we're all worried about schedule and I
can't help but be worried when I'm ever
on a film and you know you're running
behind all the shoots running behind
goes the pressure will then come from
the studio to drop sequences well haha
they can't do it so it's like studio
notes on this film haha we weren't happy
with the pace at the beginning well
tough [ __ ]
you own it we've talked about some of
the technical challenges of making a
film like this as an actor Dean when you
are having to do not only long takes
you're probably pretty far away from Sam
where he is watching your work how much
is the rehearsal process important not
just in knowing where you have to be at
a certain point in a shot but that
character instinct becoming almost
organic because there's so much muscle
memory through that rehearsal exactly I
mean it was really crucial for everybody
I mean we started rehearse in six months
before we start shooting which I mean as
an actor is pretty rare you know you
don't really get to rehearse you just
sort of step on set in front of an
already set up camera and you're still
really learning about your character as
you go along
whereas this we had the luxury to learn
about our character learn the route of
the men and and then that's basically
you know roughing it was Roger that just
said you know he was in an empty field
six months before showing literally
walking and talking the scenes you know
as they would be in the full pace and
stabbing stakes in the floor as we went
along you know like there be the corner
now there's the start point there's the
finish point and we pretty much did
don't have you saying didn't we yeah
George I'm gonna ask you about one of
the final scenes in the film when you're
running and it looks like you're in an
NFL game you're just getting creamed it
looks as if what Roger is shooting is
what's really happening can you talk
about that scene and how much is
observed and how much is random people
actually running into you it was random
people running into me genuinely we
rehearsed that for four weeks before
months before I'm built the scene you
know the first time we did it was with
20 crew members and super souped-up golf
cart and then everyone who was there on
the location scout go just get involved
get involved if you can run in between
and see what it looks like and then
months later we're there with two cranes
in a and a tracking vehicle with a crane
on the back and two grips in costume
because they can't get out of the shot
and all those explosions that you see
with their practical or practical
effects and and we rehearsed it that I
make it through
and and I didn't on the takes I got I
got knocked over so but we just kept on
going
the rule was always don't stop until you
hear cut so so we just kept going Sam
how are you directing the actors how
close are you to their to them in
performance because they're going to
long distance and how do you know as a
filmmaker what takes are working and
because obviously you have your
cinematographer your editor have to sign
up but what do you know or what are you
looking for that might be different from
them in terms of performance and how do
you have conversation given the
technical challenges that you're up
against
well you're hoping that by that time
it's pretty telepathic really I mean
you've worked so long everyone as a
group and what the extraordinary thing
was about this movie is that every
single member of every department was
engaged in every shot because they had
to be so it was none of that well this
is this refers to this department this
refers to that the bomb everybody was
involved in everything
from the very beginning and even though
the actors were rehearsing across a six
month period all they were really doing
was being part of prep from day one
which is what we would normally do but
we couldn't move without that sense of
what their natural rhythms would be the
rhythm of walking moving running the
rhythm of speech what you're trying to
do on a daily basis is judge rhythm and
tempo which is something you would never
normally do but because I'm from the
theatre that that's a more common
experience for me to judge the rhythm
and the pace of a whole two hour to an
hour hour story without recourse to cuts
so but you've got so many more elements
in this than you do with the play
everything's moving all the time the
cameras always moving the characters are
always moving the landscapes moving the
lights changing and you've got
background too and any number of things
can derail you so what I was doing was I
was working off a very large monitor
screen which I had to because I had to
see every detail because I didn't want
to let anything slip by and that meant
that I was stuck in a in a in a van as
was Roger and often we would be at the
end of the scene or at the beginnings
either way they would be starting you
know half a mile away and coming towards
us or we would be at the beginning and
they would just disappear and there were
a number of times when I had to say cut
and they couldn't hear me they just
carried on acting away down the hill and
over the horizon you know
blissfully unaware that the camera
wasn't on them anymore I mean and there
and there were days there were days I
mean there's a you've seen the movie now
there's a colonel who sits in there is
his car in the Mark Strong scene played
by wonderful article bill McCabe and you
know his experience of that was three
minutes before he had his scene was
hearing way in the distance action our
that and then eventually two minutes
into the scene someone and that you know
ad hiding in the backseat of the car
went and then he did his seem out came
mark and he bet his scene with George
and then off they went and it was
another three minutes went by and
eventually and cut our this and have art
about five takes I had this wonderful
invoice looking around said Sam I came
trotting out which again was over a hill
you know and he said where's the camera
and I said it's just behind you he said
no he said absolutely no sense of where
the crew can't see anybody I don't know
where the ADEs are there's no sign of a
camera I thought I was being Punk'd you
know and you know and at the end of the
day bless him he said well that was one
of the most enjoyable but strangest days
I've ever had on a movie because it was
like being part of a reenactment you
know he was surrounded by 300 soldiers
in full costume and everyone was
completely focused and doing it but
there was no evidence that there was a
movie being made and uh that really
tickled me but that is sometimes what it
felt like you know that you couldn't see
the crew and often they you know George
and Dean you know you know dad know if
there was no sense because obviously
we're shooting a 360 a lot of the time
so we're hiding things well we're miles
away there been a lot fair number of
movies about world war two maybe not as
much about world war one I want to ask
you a little bit about what the war
means to you you're not your film is not
about the Battle of the Somme where more
than a million people were killed or
injured fighting over a couple of miles
of land when you grew up when you heard
stories about World War one what did it
mean to you and what do you hope this
film means to people who don't know
about what happened on those
battlefields I grew up in Devon and I
still have a place in Devon and all the
little villages and towns in Devon have
a a memorial to the soldiers that died
in the First World War and the Second
World War but I particularly remember
remember crosses dedicate to the
soldiers that died in the First World
War and sometimes you'll be in a tiny
village and you'll see name after name
the same and you color at five six seven
or eight male members of that same
family died in that war and a village is
like a tiny little village in in the
countryside and I hope that it ain't not
just sticks with me I forego back there
it is those and so I really hope it's
not a history lesson up but I hope it
really inspires people to look into the
war a bit more and just because it was
such a crucial event not only in history
of the Europe but the way the world's
changed since then and yeah I agree and
there's something you know one should
remind oneself that these men were
fighting over a free and unified Europe
which in our country certainly at the
moment would be good to remember and on
top of that you know the the winds that
were blowing before this war began
blowing again and you know there's
there's it's worth remembering that a
war that can get buried under a sort of
avalanche of nationalistic cliches about
us doing it all on our own was in fact a
version of hell and and it's over a
hundred years and I hope it's not
forgotten Sam Christie Roger Lee Dean
George thank you for bringing us your
film